in Fallout 4s automatron dlc robots
invade the commonwealth and once you
breeze through of a mechanist robot army
you'll be able to make your own metal
hunk companions the more different
robots you kill and loot for their parts
the more different robot designs you get
to make so let's get right to it and
make some dope-ass bots some quick
beginner tips you're gonna want to level
up your armor and robotics perks in
order to make some of these bitchin
high-end bot parts so work forth and at
the end of the Meccan extort ooh snack
the iBot machine blueprint in the back
building one of these allows you to send
an I bought out to scavenge the
wasteland meat screws have him doing all
right let's build some butts this cryo
nozzle arm can freeze enemies ok then
we'll have one arm for freezin and the
other for ice smashing you get the idea
adding this doom helmet causes enemies
to explode sure why not meet doctor
freeze let's put them to the test
huh looks like the doom helmet wasn't
messing around these dudes be popping
let's swap helmet to see if we get some
of those frozen enemies to shatter the
basilisk air paralyzes enemies done all
set go for it freeze bummer
unfortunately I wasn't able to smash any
one whatever scrap it next up how about
an assassin bond fast nimble robot that
will dash in a battle with knives and
let some heads roll stealth blades will
do nicely and for a head perk I'm adding
the Reaper helm because it adds a chance
of decapitation let's do it first
subject here a super mutant couple
swings in oh yeah pack of gold losing
arms don't know yet both arms you gotta
love it okay lastly let's go all-out
biggest meanest dude we can build
century head with a carnage helm brings
us the chance of making these dudes
explode always a good thing and every
other piece of armor we add will beef up
this dudes damage on his back he's
packin a fat man launcher in a gas
launcher which causes enemies to frenzy
and turn on each other other than that
he's equipped with a missile launcher
and a shish kebob blade all systems go a
couple of super mutants will do fine oh
look they're fighting each other but
let's really put it to the test how
about a couple of despots
no problem oh yeah get it wait who's
throwing stones oh damn
cool well there you have it
robots are ope companions so if you are
level 15 or higher looking for some help
these buddies how to do just fine that
guy